on va parler de la course Paris
camembert qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
petit tour de table
du fromage
[Rires]
et vous c'est ninja du fromage et du
cyclisme voilà je fais une addition et
bien oui on parle bien de la mythique
course cycliste de 200 km qui relie
l'île de France à la Normandie cela
faisait 8 ans qu'elle n'était pas partie
de Magnanville pour en parler avec nous
le maire de la commune Michel Lebouc
alors selon vous qu'est-ce qui fait le
charme de cette course Paris camembert
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous évoque
après des discussions politiques que
vous avez eu dans votre introduction les
questions de plantation on va parler du
sport et le sport qui est un vecteur
d'émancipation je dis souvent et
notamment par rapport à cette course de
Paris camembert il y a camembert dedans
c'est une course mythique populaire et
dans le même temps une course qui fait
partie de la Coupe de France et la Coupe
du Monde de cycliste donc c'est une
véritable institution qu'on avait perdu
depuis quelques années à Magnanville
mais qui a toujours existé elle partait
de Normandie et elle revient aujourd'hui
à Magnanville et j'en suis très fier
pour ma commune bien entendu mais aussi
pour l'institution que représente le
vélo vous le savez aussi bien que moi
c'est que les Yvelines est une terre de
vélo on a eu le Tour de France l'année
dernière à Mantes-la-Jolie on a eu le
départ on a encore eu le départ de Paris
cette année et on avait le départ du
Paris-Nice l'année dernière
Mantes-la-Jolie aussi donc c'est une
véritable institution qui plus est comme
vous l'avez dit dans votre introduction
les JO arrivant à grands pas on va avoir
l'ensemble des courses des Jeux
Olympiques notamment le PMI la course en
ligne sur notre territoire et c'est
vraiment les Yvelines une terre de vélo
et une terre sportive voilà oui
justement à moins de 500 jours des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 c'est aussi une
manière de faire vivre ce sport le vélo
dans votre commune dans votre ville
tout à fait comme je vous le disais
c'est une véritable institution les gens
aiment bien être le long de la route
regardez le Tour de France regardez les
cyclistes passés et puis aussi on a un
bon nombre de bénévoles on a une
association à Magnanville et qui
travaille beaucoup dans le cadre de du
cyclo et c'est vraiment important pour
nous de reprendre cette course et
j'insiste là-dessus qu'une course très
mythique et qui nous fait du bien à tous
dans ce monde où l'actualité sociale et
économique est un peu perturbée c'est
vraiment un souffle qu'on va donner à
l'ensemble des manières-villoise et des
manières-villois de nos associations et
dans le même temps du territoire du
Mantois alors au total ces équipes qui
vont s'élancer sur un parcours de 200 km
pour rejoindre livaro Pays d'Auge dans
le département du Calvados avec de très
grands noms de grands coureurs de grands
sportifs
oui alors il y a eu des grands noms des
grands sportifs qui ont gagné cette
course mythique notamment pour les cités
Bernard Hinault il y a eu Laurent Fignon
alors pour ceux qui se rappellent de
l'époque yops automnales on a aussi un
yvelinois qui est très connu syndicasa
donc il fait partie du comité
d'organisation que je salue qui qui est
toujours resté en terre menteuse étant
donné que c'est un mentait pure source
qui a gagné une fois simplement cette
course au mythique qui est arrivé je
crois de mémoire deux ou trois fois
deuxième mais c'est vraiment
l'excellence du cyclisme qu'on connaît
en France et les valeurs portées par le
par le vélo
et donc cette course elle est partenaire
avec la marque de camembert le petit il
y aura des dégustations pour les plus
gourmands
alors tout à fait donc on a assez une
organisation et je salue toute mon
équipe l'équipe de Paris camembert et
mon équipe municipale notamment et le
département des Yvelines la communauté
urbaine Grand Paris senew Oise qui nous
ont aidés à construire
cette course parce que c'est c'est des
moyens quand même conséquents bien
entendu ça va commencer à partir de 9h30
de mémoire le 11 avril ou le public
pourra déambuler et rencontrer les des
coureurs professionnels il y aura aussi
bien entendu comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est Paris camembert mais je
vois sur il y aura pas que du camembert
bien entendu il y aura d'autres
surprises il y a des ateliers
recyclistes des entretiens de réparation
vélo on va faire venir nos écoles qui
doivent nous permettre d'en même temps
de donner une dynamique par rapport à
cette course
mais d'ailleurs pourquoi une marque de
camembert de fromage et partenaire de
cette d'une course de vélo
alors à l'époque sachez-le c'était
vraiment c'est comme le Paris Mantes je
sais pas si vous connaissez la marche à
pied par immense on dit Paris Mantes
mais ça part ça c'est parti de
Versailles la Paris gammembert parti à
l'époque de la de la cabine ancienne
communauté
de menthe en Yvelines et donc Paris
camembert parce qu'il y a une ville qui
s'appelle camembert et les coureurs
arrivaient à camembert aujourd'hui ça
sera plus camembert il y a ça sera
comment une ville
Vivaro juste à côté livaro marque aussi
de fromage mais le camembert le petit a
toujours été le partenaire principal de
7% voilà et alors sur le parcours il y
aura aussi quelques quelques côtes un
peu traditionnels avec 15% de dénivelé
tout à fait alors là moi je suis je dis
souvent j'aime le vélo mais le vélo ne
m'aime pas je suis un ancien rugbyman
sachez le feu donc c'est toujours
compliqué mais moi j'ai pu participer à
l'époque dans la voiture du directeur de
course à cette montée à 15 % même à pied
je pense que je la ferai pas alors il y
a plusieurs côtes qui sont de
l'ordre de 10 entre 10 et 15% mais ça va
être vraiment terrible pour les couleurs
pour les coureurs voilà
et bien merci beaucoup Michel le bouc
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors
Paris camembert c'est lancera donc de
Magnanville le mardi 11 avril à 10h45
devant l'hôtel de ville il y aura
également un village avec des animations
tout à fait plan d'animation pour les
petits les les adultes et puis les
années qui sont je dirais cher vend du
vélo comme on le voit le long des routes
du Tour de France et on estime avoir et
on espère surtout avoir beaucoup
beaucoup de monde à ce départ même si
c'est le mardi de Pâques ou on sait que
les gens sont au travail mais on sait
d'ores et déjà qu'on a des centaines et
des centaines de personnes qui viendront
au départ de la course et bien
rendez-vous mardi prochain à 10h45 à
Magnanville